[Musique]
m
la france est la nation chrétienne par
excellence à travers son histoire ce
sont souvent écrites les plus belles
pages de la chrétienté c'est le pays qui
possède le plus grand nombre de saints
dont saint martin l'apôtre de la gaule
sainteté et royautés ont façonné la
france par le baptême de clovis
la france est non seulement la fille
aînée de l'église mais aussi le premier
état d'europe et l'un des plus anciens
du monde par le sacre de charlemagne
lempire des francs qui s'étend alors sur
la france l'italie et l'allemagne unifie
la chrétienté d'occident et devient le
berceau de la civilisation européenne
par la première croisade derrière le
pape français urbain 2 et le chevalier
godefroy de bouillon
la france se fait le fer de lance de la
chrétienté combattante à l'étranger
parce louis modèle du roi chevalier
l'art politique se double d'une haute
dimension spirituelle
[Musique]
magnifiée par ces saintes patronnes que
son l'immaculée vierge marie la
guerrière jeanne d'arc et la pêcheuse
dame thérèse de lisieux
la france s'élève la femme à ses plus
nobles aspirations la cathédrale symbole
de l' architecture française eris ses
pointes de pierres vers la cime des
cieux et illumine de ses vitraux les
consciences humaines les chansons de
geste mémorial littéraires de la france
présente l'épopée de héros chrétiens
tels rolland et olivier qui affronte
géant et sarrazin quant à l'avenir de la
france selon des prophéties un grand
monarque de souche française viendra
sauver l'europe chrétienne à l'heure de
son plus grand péril l'histoire de la
france l'histoire de la chrétienté et
l'histoire de l'europe se confondent au
point qu'aucune ne serait-ce écrire sans
les deux autres
la défense de l'occident chrétien est un
concept fondateur de l'identité
française
d'où l'importance de charles martel
la première dynastie des rois de france
et celle des mérovingiens les plus
grands rois mérovingiens furent clovis
clotaire ii et dagobert premier après
dagobert commence la période des rois
fainéants l'autorité publique passe
alors entre les mains des maires du
palais une sorte de premier ministre qui
gère le royaume à la place du roi
le premier de ces gouverneurs pépin
l'ancien est l'ancêtre des pipis need et
l'arrière-grand-père de charles martel
[Musique]
c'est à et ginard biographe de
charlemagne que l'on doit la célèbre
citation sur les rois fainéants
de fait le pouvoir et l'autorité était
concentrée dans les mains des
gouverneurs de la résidence royale qu'on
appelait maire du palais et à qui
appartenait le commandement suprême en
rien d'autre n'était laissé au roi que
le nom de roi la chevelure débordante
labarde pendante
il avait seulement les satisfactions de
ce kg sur son trône et d'être façonné à
l'image d'un seigneur
ou qu'il se rendit il allait en char à
boeufs prennez par un bouvier à la mode
campagnarde
fruit de cette confusion politique
divers bars on en vient à revendiquer la
mairie du palais de leur région et un
climat de guerre civile s'installe dans
687 et peint le gros descendants de
pépin l'ancien est alors maire du palais
d'austrasie le nord-est de la france à
la bataille de tertry il remporte une
victoire décisive qui lui permet de
réunir entre ses mains la plus grande
partie du royaume des francs
c'est un tournant jusqu'à dagobert
l'unité du royaume ne pouvait se faire
qu'autour d'un roi à partir de pépin le
gros c'est au tour du maire du palais
que se fait l'unité du pays
dans les banques et festif qui arrose la
victoire de tertry pépin legros délaisse
son épouse plectre rude pour sa
maîtresse al baïd de cette union
adultérine n'est en 688 charles martel
une chronique de l'époque décrit
brièvement l'adultère de pépin le gros
et le caractère de son fils illégitime
le principe est pas eu d'une autre femme
un fils nommé charles c'était un homme
d'élite élégant et habile bien que
batteur charles martel reçoit une
éducation de prince
il apprend à monter à cheval et s'exerce
au maniement des armes discipline viril
ou ressort son tempérament de chef qui
lui attire de solides amitiés
[Musique]
on
à
c'est aussi dans ces années
d'apprentissage que charles vit ses
premières amours
[Musique]
puis le preux chevalier épouse une jolie
demoiselle d'une ou deux recrues
[Musique]
m
charles héros trude auront deux fils
carloman et pépin le bref ainsi qu'une
fille aude
[Musique]
e
pepa legros meurt en 714 conséquences
fâcheuses de la vie dissolue du
patriarche la succession se passe mal
[Musique]
d'un côté plectre ud entend assurer seul
la régence durant la minorité de
théodore halde
un enfant de 6 ans qui est le petit fils
légitime la veuve obtient le soutien de
plusieurs évêques influents tels lambert
l'évêque de maastricht et rigobert
l'évêque de reims de l'autre charles
revendique pour lui même la mairie du
palais et compte sur sa garde rapprochée
pour satisfaire ses desseins politiques
[Musique]
lors d'un plaid l'assemblée des barons
décide de confier l'autorité appelé kt
rude
[Musique]
pour se prémunir contre tout coup d'état
la régente ordonne aussitôt d'arrêter
son fillatre charme et de le jeter dans
les geôles de son palais de colonne
[Musique]
et
mais plectre une nappe al'étoffe de feu
son époux et les régions autrefois
réunis sous la poigne de pépin l'euro
reprennent leurs divisions
[Musique]
un froid duc d'anjou était le chef
militaire de la neustrie une région qui
correspond au nord-ouest de la france
ambitieux il rêve de devenir l'homme
fort du royaume et se prépare à la lutte
[Musique]
le 26 septembre 715 près de compiègne il
remporte une victoire sur les
australiens de plexus
c'est le début d'une succession de
batailles entre francs il s'ensuivit
deluxe et des représailles grande
impétueuse parmi le peuple des francs au
cours de la mêlée un froid réussi à
s'emparer du roi dagobert 3
c'est un acte important car le roi bien
que fainéants et la légalité vivante qui
tient le roi tient le pouvoir rpt à
froid se fait introniser maire du palais
de nostri puis il fait supprimer
dagobert 3 et nomme un nouveau roi
chilpéric 2 qui est bien sûr sa créature
la guerre civile franck tourner bientôt
au conflit international
leno strien s'allie aux païens frison
ensemble ils vont pas siéger cologne où
s'est retranché plectre hughes et le
siège porte ses fruits au printemps 716
pour s'éviter un malheur plus grand pelé
krug achète la paix et remet un lourd
tribut aux envahisseurs
[Musique]
le bilan politique de plectre ud et
calamiteux l'austrasie et vaincu ruine
et humilie alors dans la panique
on organise un nouveau plaide et les le
choisissent cette fois de s'en remettre
à l'homme providentiel qui croupit dans
le cachot humide plectre ud est congédié
l'austrasie se donne à charles martel en
séjour le duc charles qui étaient tenus
sous bonne garde par ladite femme
plectre ud fut avec l'aide de dieu y
libérer
le chef des francs de l'est prend
immédiatement l'initiative
[Musique]
avec ses fidèles ils se ruent à la
poursuite des must rien de rein foie et
chilpéric 2 le 8 juillet 716 à amblève
dans les ardennes scheurle tend une
embuscade aux lost rien qui fait dans
l'ivresse leur récent triomphe de
cologne
[Musique]
se croyant à l'abri du danger les
soldats de rein froid et chilpéric
prennent du bon temps sous l'épée
feuillage tandis que le vin et le soleil
d'été engourdissent les consciences
[Musique]
c'était l'heure du déjeuner et l'armée
de chilpéric comme le lui conseillaient
la saison d'été se restaurer sous les
tentes et les ombrages soudain au signal
convenu les australiens asahi l'ennemi
et charles remporte une première
victoire sur un froid qui s'échappe sans
gloire
un hiver passe puis le 21 mars 717
charles remporte une deuxième victoire à
20 si près de cambrai en flandre sûr de
sa puissance
il pousse son avantage jusqu'à paris et
entre dans la capitale du royaume
fort de son triomphe militaire charles
retourne à cologne où il se fait
introniser maire du palais d'austrasie
en guise de caution dynastique il place
à ses côtés un miro vin vient de
pacotille
clotaire 4,7 en aquitaine que rhin froid
et chilpéric trouvent refuge
l'aquitaine est alors quasi autonome
cette région d'où ces latine est dirigée
par eudes un duc pragmatique à ces âges
et un froid exposé à eux deux les
déboires de la neustrie et réclame son
aide contre charles martel le duc de
toulouse accepte une coalition est ainsi
créé qui l'unît l'industrie et
l'aquitaine les intentions du duc
d'aquitaine sont évidentes
faisant sien le vieil adage diviser pour
mieux régner
eudes espère alimenter la guerre civile
chez ces turbulent voisin du nord mais
hull a dangereusement sous-estimer son
adversaire le 14 octobre 719
charles martel écrase la coalition à
néry en picardie
[Musique]
une paix et finalement signé entre
charles et eudes français aquitain
n'ayant aucun intérêt à la poursuite de
ce conflit
les rois clotaire cap et chilpéric deux
sont assassinés et charles nomme un
nouveau et unique roi pour tout le
royaume thierry 4
kantar un froid il s'en retourne seul
dans son fief angevins et se résignera
lui aussi à la paix entre 714 et 721 il
y aura eu quatre rois fainéants dagobert
3 chilpéric 2 clotaire 4 et thierry 4
jouets malheureux entre les mains avides
des deux mers du palais charles hérin
froid grands vainqueurs de la guerre
civile
charles tient désormais seul les rênes
du pouvoir à la fois audacieux et
prudent il est le véritable chef de
l'état sans remettre en cause la
monarchie héréditaire ayant assis son
autorité et réaliser l'unité des francs
charles va pouvoir se consacrer aux
affaires étrangères
par la nature des choses gaulle et
germany sont voisines leurs querelles ou
leur amitié ont souvent rythmé les
événements d'europe de l'ouest
la gaule jadis était païenne au tréfonds
des forêts feuillues c'est druide
présidait aux destinées de la patrie et
au sacrifice en l'honneur des dieux
bercé par le chant sacré des bardes les
guerriers il prononçait le serment
politique avant de partir au front mais
les défait de vercingétorix
en -52 puis de baux à 10 c en bretagne
en l'an 61 avaient finalement conduit
les seuls à intégrer l'empiré romain
aussitôt connecter aux divers réseaux de
lempire les celtes pour acquérir les
savoirs gréco latins et dès l'époque des
évangiles participer activement à la
naissance de la civilisation chrétienne
en s'émancipant du paganisme gaulle et
bretagne ont ainsi en fonte et dessins
des abbayes et des textes littéraires au
contraire des celtes les germains
avaient réussi à repousser les légions
conquérante du latium la victoire d'are
minus en l'an 9
épargna aux germains l'insertion à
lempire
mais cette liberté sauvage eu un prix
elle les aura isolé de la marche du
monde et de l'essor du christianisme et
ce pour de nombreux siècles
[Musique]
durant le haut moyen âge les autres de
l'europe centrale vécurent toujours à
l'orée de l'histoire
[Musique]
m
au viiie siècle on en voit les
conséquences
[Musique]
alors que la gaule chrétien n'a fait son
unité politique et dispose d'un état
central fort sous l'égide de charles
martel la germanie peine à se trouver
émiettez en une myriade de tribus régis
par des roitelets tantôt chrétiens tant
aux païens pourtant le rapport de forces
est plus subtil qu'il n'y paraît car
l'anarchie n'est pas toujours gage de
faiblesse militaire
de mémoire d'homme à l'époque jamais la
germanie n'a été conquise par personne
ni le grand césar ni l'empereur auguste
ni plus tard les rois mérovingiens
clovis clotaire 2 dagobert
personne n'est jamais parvenu à envahir
ce territoire d'europe centrale aux
frontières floues et aux populations
disparates
[Musique]
comme ses prédécesseurs charles a maille
à partir avec les belliqueuse tribus qui
hantent les forêts d'outre-rhin
notamment vers 720 il lance une violente
offensive contre les saxons la même
année le prince dévastée à la saxe honni
par une grande saignée et parvint
jusqu'à la vézère ayant soumis tout le
pays
il s'en revint victorieux dans son
domaine
[Musique]
mais à défaut de vaincre l'hydre païenne
l'occident doit sans cesse repoussé la
menace du chaos germanique et tout reste
à refaire
par ailleurs depuis déjà plusieurs
générations des missionnaires chrétiens
avaient pris pied sur le sol germanique
là avec patience et abnégation
les serviteurs de dieu s'efforce
d'enseigner aux masses indigènes les
préceptes du sauveur mais les couvents
trop épars et mal défendu sont
constamment l'objet de pillage de la
part de roitelets payen cette double
paire s'est désarmé franck et des
communautés religieuses se fait
séparément
d'où leur manque de résultats durables
alors le pape grégoire 2 prend une
initiative en novembre 723 il invite à
rome un moine anglais déjà célèbre pour
son apostolat en terre païenne du nord
ce moine séverine fried plus connu sous
le nom de saint boniface le pape confie
à boniface le périlleux évêché de frise
sur l'estuaire du rhin avec la charge de
poursuivre sa croisade contre les tribus
échevelé de germanie le saint père
italien fait aussi de l'apôtre anglais
son messager auprès de charles martel
l'idée de grégoire 2 est d'associer la
puissante armée des francs à l'éloquence
dialectique des moines
l'apache est inédite et promet d'être
efficace c'est l'alliance officiel de
l'épée et de la crosse quant à charles
saisissant l'occasion d'accroître son
emprise sur la germanie tout en servant
la puissante église
il donne aussitôt son accord des 725 le
maire du palais envoie ses armées sur la
souabe puis sur la bavière pour en
pacifier les territoires rebelles
les années suivantes d'autres percées
militaire suivront au gré des nécessités
a brisé la témérité païenne et à
soutenir l'élan missionnaire sa femme
ruth rude étant décédé charles profitent
de ces campagnes étrangères pour en
ramener une demoiselle bavaroise du nom
de saône field qu'il épousera en
secondes noces
après avoir rassemblé une armée charles
traversa le rhin parcouru la les manies
et parvint jusqu'au danube qui franchit
les s'empara de la bavière l'ayant
soumises
il s'en revint à victorieux grâce à dieu
sur ses propres terres avec à trésors
considérable ainsi qu'une dame nommée
belt rude et sa nièce
sonnhild
ainsi la première action internationale
de charles martel et d'avoir oeuvré avec
énergie à l'expansion de l'influencé
franck à l'est du rhin et à la
christianisation de la germanie
si le maire du palais était mort envers
730 il aurait déjà laissé de lui le
souvenir d'un chef d'état courageux et
intelligent il a gagné la guerre civile
de 714 il a continué l'unification de la
gauche il a consolidé la puissance
militaire du royaume de là il a été
sollicité par le pape grégoire 2 pour
aider à l'évangélisation de l'europe
centrale
ce bilan politique déjà méritoire n'est
pourtant pas ce qu'ont retenu en premier
de lui les générations suivantes
[Musique]
un péril mortel s'approche de l'europe
chrétienne
et l'europe chrétienne ne le sait pas
encore dans les sables chauds d'arabie
une autre civilisation une autre race
une autre religion émergent
[Musique]
le prophète mahomet nevers 570 à la
mecque et meurt en 632 à médine
le fondateur de l'islam à environ 40 ans
quand il commence la rédaction de ce qui
va devenir le corps mais nul n'est
prophète en son pays
c'est premier prêche ne convainquent pas
il doit fuir la mecque pour médine à 300
km au nord cette fuite hégire en arabe
correspond à l'enim de l'ère islamique à
médine les populations lui font en
revanche bon accueil
c'est la création du premier état
islamique au monde
à la mort de mahomet ses successeurs
poursuivre l'extension de l'état
islamique
toujours en quête d' espaces à convertir
vers l'an 700 l'un des tentacules de
l'armée musulmane et déjà aux portes de
l'espagne depuis la chute de rome
l'ibérie était en grande partie gouverné
par les wisigoths un peuple de souche
germanique qui s'y étaient installés
lors des grandes migrations aux
quatrième et cinquième siècle
or ce royaume wisigoth qui date pourtant
de près de trois siècles est gangréné
par une guerre civile en 711 une troupe
musulmane traversent la méditerranée et
opère un premier débarquement en
andalousie
ces musulmans sont des arabes mais aussi
des berbères fraîchement convertis à la
bataille du bois d'allaiter les
mahométans ont mené par le général tariq
écrase l'armée germanique rodrigues le
roi des wisigoths y trouvent la mort
c'est l'effondrement
bientôt le gouverneur omeyyades musa
débarque à son tour avec de gros
renforts
poursuivant sur leur lancée les
disciples dallas absorbe la presque
totalité de la péninsule ibérique connue
désormais sous le nom de sarrasin ils
placent leur capital à cordoue
les conquérants islamique sont
accueillis favorablement par l'influente
communauté juive dont les intrigues
locales ont pu faciliter l'invasion
[Musique]
l'ibérie vaincu les musulmans ils font
venir leurs familles
cette première vague de sarrasin
comprend environ soixante mille immigrés
il y en aura beaucoup d'autres au fil du
temps quand plusieurs communautés
doivent partager le même espace vital
la règle de vie n'est pas le métissage
mais l'affrontement où la ségrégation
les peuples obéissent en effet aux mêmes
instincts que les animaux
l'islam n'est pas à proprement parler
une religion spirituelle très éloigné du
message d'amour et de liberté de
l'évangile le coran est en fait une
constitution politique la loi coranique
ou charia réglemente tous les domaines
de la vie
la prière et l'aumône certes mais aussi
la nourriture
le vêtement le port de la barbe et même
les procédures à respecter pour
l'héritage ou les métiers de la banque
dans l'islam tout est codifié le livre
saint des mahométans et ans et tortueuse
sorin tu as tous les domaines de
l'existence rues boutiques
administration armée vient team
le but ultime de l'islam consiste en
l'instauration d'un califat totalitaire
à l'ensemble du monde
quant au peuple qui refuseront la parole
du prophète
celui-ci leur réserve un statut
discriminatoire la dhimma le mot dima
signifie protection en arabe les 10 me
c'est à dire ceux qui sont soumis à la
dhimma ont obligation de s'acquitter
d'un lourd impôt envers la communauté
musulmane et ils ont entre autres
interdiction de porter des armes
interdiction de mettre une selle alors
cheval interdiction d'élever la voix
devant un musulman interdiction de faire
des processions religieuses interdiction
d'avoir un clocher plus haut que le
minaret
à l'occasion les nouveaux maîtres
n'hésite donc pas à transformer de
belles églises séculaire en mosquée en
andalousie islamique
les nouveaux venus décide de battre
monnaie et la légende de ces pièces est
riche d'enseignements des 716 les dinars
sont bilingues latins et arabes en 720
le latin disparaît ne reste que l'arabe
l'archéologie ne témoigne d'aucun
métissage idéologique par exemple
l'islam d'espagne n'intègre pas
d'élément chrétiens à partir de 711
l'ibérie européenne et chrétienne plonge
dans les abysses et sort de l'histoire
durant le haut moyen âge les juifs
possède l'insigne privilège du trafic
d'esclaves en europe
la plaque tournante de ce juteux
commerce et verdun les esclaves sont des
païens de souche germanique ou slaves
une marchandise blonde aux yeux clairs
que les fils d'isaac revendre au prix
fort en espagne sarrasine au maghreb
de leur côté les musulmans se livrent à
la piraterie
[Musique]
ils font des razia sur les côtes
méditerranéennes de l'europe du sud trop
exposés et mal défendu les sarrasins et
capturent des familles voire des
villages entiers qu'ils acheminent toute
chaîne cv vers les divers soupe de la
maison de l'islam
[Musique]
après la chute de l'ibérie sous la
férule du coran l'armée islamique
poursuit son expansion vers la gaule
en 719 un gouverneur arabe nommé sam a
franchi pour la première fois les
pyrénées longeant la méditerranée
il conquiert narbonne puis étend son
influence alentours
les musulmans ravage les villes
incendies les bâtiments violent les
femmes emmène des esclaves
pour beaucoup de victimes c'est
l'instant tragique de toute une vie
[Musique]
oh
aveuglé par ses succès sommes assez
l'once vers la garonne pour prendre
toulouse mais contre toute attente
toulouse résiste le 9 juin 721 le duc
eudes remporte la première victoire de
l'occident chrétien contre les arabes
islamiques au cours de la mêlée
sama et tuer les envahisseurs repoussé
mais non anéanti s'enfuit derrière leur
nouveau chef
abd al rahman par cette victoire eu de
d'aquitaine devient le sauveur de la
civilisation chrétienne le pape grégoire
2 le félicite
si les musulmans avaient renoncé à la
gaule la postérité aurait sans doute
gardé le souvenir d'eux mais il va en
être autrement
vers 7 125 depuis barcelone qui leur
sert de base arrière les sarrasins se
ruent à nouveau vers le nord et s'empare
cette fois des bouches du rhône cette
intrusion fulgurante et ferait des chefs
politiques locaux certains songent pas
trahir leur civilisation
dont un certain moore honte qui fait
office de maire de marseille plutôt que
d'essayer de résister à l'envahisseur
à l'exemple du duc eudes mort on préfère
acheter la paix il accepte la dhimma il
se fait 10 me ils paient un tribut aux
musulmans et leur met des otages or la
lâcheté et contagieuse bientôt le doute
se diffuse dans les consciences en cette
129e 2 se rapproche lui aussi des
musulmans
le duc d'aquitaine n'est certes pas un
dhimmi telle mort honte mais il estime
qu'une entente est possible avec
certains musulmans
il sait qu arabes et berbères ne
s'aiment guère les arabes ayant en effet
coutume de mépriser les peuples
maghrébins
alors eu de quoi judicieux de marier sa
fille l'an pj au petit chef berbère moon
usa qui gouvernent les
pyrénées-orientales
[Musique]
oh
mais cette alliance dynastique n'est pas
du goût des deux chefs d'états voisins
tout au nord charles martel s'interroge
pourquoi eu de doute il soudain des
relations amicales avec ses ennemis
d'hier
après tout si le chef de la garonne
voulait marier sa fille lampes et j
pourquoi n'at-il pas pris contact avec
l'aristocratie franck tout au sud
le chef islamique abd al-rahman se pose
la même question
six minutes un voulait se marier
que n'at-il épousé une princesse arabe
et islamique à la place d'une duchesse
gauloise et chrétienne
[Musique]
pressé d'en finir avec ce simulacre de
vivre ensemble abd al-rahman rassemble
son armée et assaillent le menu domaine
de mu à la mêlée et brel la victoire
sans nuance le roi tôt les berbères est
capturé et décapité
quant à l'innocence lampes et j elle
paye le prix de la candeur de son père
[Musique]
oh
réduites en esclavage la fille 2
d'aquitaine est aussitôt expédié au
harem du khalife de damas charles se
méfie du duc d'aquitaine qu'ils jugent
sournois et comploteurs eudes en effet
n'avait pas hésité à s'allier autrefois
art un froid puis naguère amusa il n'y a
qu'avec charles qu'il ne voulait pas
s'allier
alors le maire du palais de france lance
une incursion en aquitaine en 731 ils
pillent le nord de la région et en
ramène un solide butin la situation
devient critique
il a joué il a beaucoup perdu
désormais il se voit pris en tenaille
entre le chef des sarrasins au sud et le
chef des francs honore et les événements
vont s'accélérer
abd al-rahman cogite une nouvelle
offensive sur la gaule
il se souvient de l'échec des siens
devant toulouse en 721 ils cherchent une
autre route vers le nord début 732 son
choix se porte sur la côte atlantique à
la tête de son armée
il traverse les pyrénées ravagent le
pays basque est galopant d'eurasia en
razia s'empare de bordeaux eux
désemparée mais combatif cfer d'opposer
une résistance a redit le long de la
garonne
mais ces troupes sont insuffisantes
rapidement il doit battre en retraite
avec ces derniers zone
l'aquitaine s'écroule abd al-rahman
triomphe poitiers subi le martyre des
flammes
[Musique]
en ligne de mire les sarrasins lorgne
sur la rive basilique saint martin de
tours avec la roi abd al-rahman les
sarrasins traverser la garonne et
parvint à bordeaux là les églises de
dieu furent consumés par le feu et de
nombreux chrétiens tués ils avancèrent
jusqu'à poitiers la basilique sainte
hilaire fut incendiée plein d'élan il
tendait leur marche vers l'église saint
martin de tours pour l'anéantir
vaincus mais vivant le duc eudes
s'échappe vers le nord et sollicite
l'aide de son ancien rival l'accueil que
lui réservent à charles fut peut-être
chaleureux le césar déchu suscite
désormais la pitié dans sa chronique
paul diacre écrit malgré la mésentente
qui régnait alors entre salles et eu de
presse de l'aquitaine il faire front
ensemble et lutter n'a comme un accord
contre les sarrasins
face à la menace sarrasine les querelles
de famille s'estompe charles mobilisent
sans tarder son armée
les chevaliers franc passe partout puis
s'enfonce dans les plaines du poitou au
devant d'eux les nus
la rencontre entre l'armé chrétienne et
l'armée islamique se situe près de
poitiers à vouneuil sur vienne au
lieu-dit de mousser la bataille on naît
le 18 octobre
732 là deux civilisations s'observe d'un
côté derrière charles martel des hommes
de race blanche de religion chrétienne
et de langues européennes de l'autre
derrière abd al-rahman des hommes de
race foncé de religion islamique et de
langues sémitiques tout les sépare
pendant plusieurs jours de part et
d'autre on s'adonne à des escarmouches
on jauge la situation on repère les
points névralgiques
surtout on attend avant même les
premiers chants des p les probabilités
de l'emporter divergent d'un camp à
l'autre
sharm al avantage du temps il n'est pas
pressé il défend son propre pays avec
l'appui de la population locale pour lui
la question de l'intendance ne se pose
pas il trouvera toujours de quoi nourrir
ses hommes et ses chevaux il a même tout
intérêt à vider les silos de la région a
emmené le grain à déplacer les bestiaux
en lieu sûr à pratiquer une politique de
terre brûlée son plan poussé les
sarrasins à la faute
abd al-rahman commence à douter de sa
baraka pour la première fois il s'est
enfoncé fort loin de son royaume
ibérique
que c'est-il de la gaule ses rivières
ses ponts ses routes son relief
et puis il y a le problème de
l'intendance comment nourrir ses soldats
et ses chevaux en terre hostile
le prince mahométan et donc pousser à
prendre l'initiative sur une terre qu'il
ne connaît pas avec une logistique
précaire loin des siens et sans secours
à attendre au glissement du crépuscule
abd al-rahman se retire avec les siens
dans la solitude du pouvoir
ils pressent peut-être qu'il s'est
aventuré trop loin
comment se déroule à la bataille une
donnée technique offre peut être une
ébauche de réponse
c'est au tour du viiie siècle que fut
inventée l'étrier en offrant aux
chevaliers une meilleure assise sur la
selle l'étrier permet de frapper des
stocks l'ennemi d'où cette nouveauté de
tenir une longue de lens brandi en avant
pour défoncer la cible chose évidemment
impossible sans étriers car le choc
frontal aurait éjecté le chevalier en
arrière montés sur leurs chevaux les
francs sont alignés en rangs serrés
il s'agit pour eux d'empêcher l'ennemi
de se faufiler entre les lignes
les chevaliers de charles martel
présente donc une densité massive de
loin les boucliers scintille
tel un mur de glace réfléchissant la
lumière
[Musique]
cette hypothèse semble confirmée par la
chronique mozarabes à ce moment pendant
sept jours
les deux adversaires se harcèlent pour
choisir le lieu de la bataille
puis enfin se préparent au combat mais
pendant qu'ils combattent avec violence
les gens du nord demeurant à première
vue immobile comme un mur restent serrés
les uns contre les autres
telle une zone de froid glacial les
chrétiens nordique attendent le signal
de leur chef les sarrasins eux sont déjà
au galop ils approchent
soudain sur ordre de charles résonne
trompette et oliphant les français lance
et brandissent leurs banques comme
autant déduit y ont meurtrier dès le
début de la mêlée les pointes de fer
percent les boucliers islamique et en
broche la chaire ennemis dans les duels
abdel rahmane trouvent la mort les
envahisseurs sont écrasés charles martel
triomphe
la chronique de frais des guerres
raconte avec l'aide du christ
charles renversa leur tante couru au
combat faire un carnage puis le roi abd
al rahman tué il les terrasses à broyat
leurs armes et les vins qui est laid
soumis
la victoire des chrétiens est totale
[Musique]
les coûts de cette bataille est franchie
bientôt les frontières le britannique
ben le vénérable écrit à cette époque
les sarrasins comme un terrible fléau
ravageur la gaule y commettant d'atroces
destruction après quoi dans ce même pays
ils eurent à payer le prix de leur as
famille preuve du caractère
civilisationnel de l'événement c'est
suite à cette bataille que pour la
première fois des chroniqueurs utilise
le mot européens pour évoquer les
vainqueurs de poitiers poitiers jette
donc les fondations de ce que sera
l'europe le continent de race blanche et
de civilisation chrétienne
[Musique]
après poitiers toute la chrétienté
d'europe chante les louanges de charles
martel et un halo de légende s'empare
bientôt 2,7 fulgurant victoire dans son
palais le prince des francs organise un
immense banquet où les anciens
combattants racontent leur pétillant
aventure c'est à ce moment que charles
aurait reçu le surnom de martel
peut-être le marteau de charme fait-il
allusion à la tribu d'un ancien dieu
païen car les vieux mythes celte était
alors encore bien vivace assises à ses
tables bruyante des trouvères écoute et
mémorise les exploits des soldats pour
revenus du poitou invincible
mêlant événements réels et contes
anciens les jongleurs de mots vont
donner naissance aux fameuses chansons
de geste
la mémoire ethnique fut toutefois
ingrate envers charles martel
car le viiie siècle va offrir à l'europe
un autre personnage haut en couleur qui
est le petit fils du champion de
poitiers
par un transfert épique d'un charles à
un autre charles c'est charlemagne qui
est devenu le roi de la matière de
france pourtant les faits historiques
sont pérennes
le charles chef des armées franck et
chrétienne qui guerroient ya des années
contre les sarrasins islamique
ce n'est pas charlemagne qui pour sa
part échange avec eu d'amical ambassade
mais bien son aïeul le maire du palais
ainsi dans les poèmes épiques sous la
célèbre barbe fleurie de l'empereur
charlemagne pointe en réalité la
pilosité de charles martel les chansons
de geste étant les premiers textes
d'importance en français
cela pose la question de la date de
naissance de la langue 842 et la date la
plus ancienne connue de vieux français
il s'agit d'un document appelé le
serment de strasbourg ce serment fut
prononcé à haute voix par charles le
chauve et louis le germanique chacun
dans la langue de l'autre et devant
leurs peuples rassembler afin de se
promettre une paix mutuelle le texte
français disait pour l'amour de dieu et
pour le peuple chrétien et notre salut
commun à partir d'aujourd'hui en tant
que dieu me donnera savoir et pouvoir
jeu secours est semi un frère charles
par mon aide et en toutes choses comme
on doit se courir son frère selon les
cuites et à condition qu'ils fassent de
même pour moi et je ne tiendrais jamais
avec lothaire au cap led qui de ma
volonté puisse être dommageable à mon
frère charles si en 842 existe une trace
écrite de français
au point que l'on demande au roi louis
le germanique de s'exprimer dans cette
langue pour être compris du peuple de
charles le chauve
cela signifie que le peuple de charles
le chauve parlait déjà couramment cette
langue
lors du serment de strasbourg
étaient présents des guerriers d'une
trentaine d'années né sous charlemagne
et des hommes d'âge mûr nes ou pépin le
bref et comme il y eut toujours des
centenaire s'il en fut un le jour de ce
serment cette honorable doyen était né
sous charles martel selon toute
vraisemblance les prémices de la langue
française orale remonte donc un siècle
avant le serment de strasbourg voire
davantage au banquet de charles martel
certains de table parlait déjà français
les plaines poitevine ont aussi conservé
le souvenir de cette époque
après avoir bouté les sarrasins port de
gaulle charles martel se serait rendu
dans la chapelle sainte-catherine de
fierbois au sud de tours
dans cette église le glorieux maire du
palais offre à dieu son épais qu'il
dépose précieusement au pied de l'autel
le temps passe et pour de nombreux
siècles recouvre cette sainte anne du
sault de l'oubli mais quand le royaume
connaîtra de nouveaux tourments en 14
129 les voix du ciel révéleront à jeanne
d'arc l'existence du glaive de charles
martel et où le trouver
voici ce qu'elle dit lors de son procès
tandis que j'étais à tous j'envoyais
chercher une épée qui se trouvaient dans
l'église sainte-catherine de fierbois
derrière l'autel comment saviez vous que
cet ep fut là cet ep était en terre tout
rouillé et la garde et est ornée de
sainte croix
je su qu'à se trouver là par mes voix
est l'homme qu'il alla chercher ne
l'avez jamais vu j'écrivis aux
ecclésiastiques du lieu qu'ils blues
bien m'envoyer cette épée et il me
l'envoie hier elle n'était pas trop
enfoncé en terre derrière l'autel comme
il me semble aussitôt après que les
députés trouver les états à sic du lieu
l'afro terre et aussitôt la roue tourne
a sans difficulté la pucelle qui
libérera orléans du joug anglais aurait
tenu en main l'épée du vainqueur de
poitiers
[Musique]
la victoire de poitiers n'est pas une
fin en soi mais le début de la
reconquête
c'est l'aube de la renaissance
occidentale beaucoup restait à accomplir
youssef le fils d'abdallah rahman
gouverner alors narbonne habile
diplomate
il avait noué des liens avec mort honte
le maire de marseille est mort honte
politiciens l'arche lui avait cédé
avignon de là certains sarrazin ont
commencé d'explorer les berges du rhône
et même au delà
valence vienne lyon autun pour enrayer
cette intrusion étrangère des 733
charles martel déploie des contingents
militaires dans le sud est avec son
armée il entre en burgondie et y place
des fidèles aux divers postes de
commandement
[Musique]
l'année 733 le prince charles pénétra
dans le royaume de burgondie avec des
guerriers vigoureux est il remis ce
territoire assez fidèle à ses duc les
plus peureux pour le régenter la il
délègue son autorité à son frère chip de
brando qui devient duc de bure bondi en
cette 135e demeure de vieillesse son
fils une eau lui succède sur le duché
d'aquitaine après avoir dû prêter
hommage à charles martel
si l'on tire un bilan politique en 735
charles martel étant son gouvernement a
presque toute la gaule il en tient
personnellement la moitié nord austrasie
et nostre son frère schilde brand dirige
la burgondie et s'efforce de libérer la
provence est une ode aquitaine reconnaît
la souveraineté des francs mais toutes
ces années les côtes méditerranéennes
ont souffert des ravages islamique les
griffes du coran en serre avignon et
chim de brand peine à pacifier le delta
du rhône alors en 737 charles d'essence
sur les routes du soleil avec du
matériel de guerre et délivre la cité
comme à jéricho au milieu du fracas des
armées et au son des trompettes avec des
machines de guerre et des échelles de
cordes
ils se ruent sur les hautes murailles
pénètre dans cette ville bien fortifiée
lincendie capturent leurs ennemis
étrangers les tuent les trucide les
abattent et rétablisse avec succès leur
autorité il est possible que ce matériel
de sièges apportée par charles martel
soit aussi l'occasion de tester une
innovation technologique
jadis au temps des romains pour projeter
de grosses masses on usait de catapultes
l'inconvénient de ce type d'engin c'est
que son énergie dépens de l'élasticité
d'un resort fait de bois tendre ou d'un
nerf de boeuf
or sous le climat pluvieux de la gaule
l'humidité risque de détendre le ressort
de la machine et de la rendre inopérante
d'où l'invention de la perrière au haut
moyen âge
cet engin astucieux présente une hélice
sur un axe vertical une corde actionner
vigoureusement par quelques hommes fait
tourner cette hélice ce qui est gect de
la poche de cuir un boulet de quelques
kilos on atteint ainsi une cible à 60
mètres à la cadence de 60 tirs à leur
avantage de la perrière sur la catapulte
c'est qu'elle est utilisable par tous
les temps même sous la pluie
comme pour les trier les machines de
guerre à balancier ouvre une nouvelle
ère dans l'art de la guerre
vaincus et pourchassés par les francs
les sarrasins évacue la provence et se
replie sur narbonne derrière ses
murailles youssef fils d'abdallah
rahmane c'est puissamment retranché et
il a eu la prudence d'appeler à son
secours
les troubles islamique rester en espagne
pour charles martel le péril est sérieux
il c'est narbonne difficile à prendre
parant au plus pressé il laisse quelques
troupes autour de la cité et marche avec
le gros de l'armée au devant des
renforts mahométans
[Musique]
beaucoup
c'est dans la vallée des corbières près
des rivières de la berre et de l'aude
que se déroule la bataille commun à
rible khaled le général sarrazin y
trouvent la mort ces soldats sont
massacrés ou tentent de s'enfuir par les
eaux souvent en vain les rescapés
cherche à s'échapper en embarquant sur
des bateaux en nageant dans la lagune
l'effort de chacun fait qu'il bondisse
les uns sur les autres
bientôt les francs avec des bateaux et
des armes de jet bondissent sur eux et
les tue en les noyant cette victoire de
l'aber sonne le glas des velléités
islamique sur la gaule la septimanie
libéré seul narbonne résistera encore
quelques temps avant d'être conquise en
759 par pépin le bref fils de charles
martel
tant de malheurs fut le fruit certes de
la témérité sarrasine mais aussi de la
trahison de certaines élites locales
une fois la gaule délivré charles martel
venge l'infamie et punit les félons il
cherche notamment le fameux mort honte
ce chef marseille à qui avait choisi le
statut de dhimmi mais le judas de la
provence avait pris soin de préparer ses
arrières
il courut se terrer dans les calanques
d'où il ne revint jamais parvenu à la
hâte à aligne au charles rétablie sauf à
domination tout le pays jusqu'au
littoral méditerranéen
tandis que le duc mauron s'échapper dans
les falaises impénétrable abrité et
protégé par la mer au sortir des guerres
islamique d année 730 les sarrasins sont
les grands perdants
abd al rahman a été vaincue et tué dans
le poitou son fils youssef survit
difficilement derrière les murailles de
narbonne omar ibn khaled et son armée
ont disparu dans les marécages du
languedoc
côté chrétien les plus irrésolu connu un
sort déplorable eudes le vainqueur de
toulouse avait fini par renoncer à la
lutte
il fut balayé par la tornade de 732 ça
file en pj termine à ses jours dans un
lointain arènes mort honte le traître de
marseille avait choisi la soumission à
l'ennemi il dut s'exiler dans des lieux
sauvages l'histoire a donné raison à
charles martel sa stratégie offensive et
persévérante était la bonne
son audace technique à payer le royaume
chrétien des francs émergent des luttes
civilisationnel plus fort et plus
rayonnante que jamais
[Musique]
en 737 le roi
et en thierry 4 décède charles prend
alors une décision aussi prudente car
dit il ne le remplace pas la france
devient un royaume sans roi une
situation inédite
le maire du palais échafaudant fait un
coup politique à longue portée ambitieux
il a maintes fois nourris la tentation
de se faire sacrer roi mais un coup
d'état
l'ugtt entraîné dans un tourbillon
d'incertitude en eux proclamant roi ni
un nouveau mérovingiens ni lui même le
chef des francs ménages la puissante
aristocratie tout en préparant avec
patience sinon pour lui du moins pour sa
propre descendance les marches du sacre
royal
la désuétude d'en référer à la dynastie
mérovingienne
tôt ou tard profitera à la lignée du
vainqueur de poitiers
tout n'est que question de temps en
attendant il confie l'éducation de ses
fils carloman et pépin le bref à
l'influente basilique saint denis les
rapports entre charles martel et
l'église sont ambigus et reflètent les
dérèglements moreau de l'époque
dépassant les limites de son champ
d'action politique le maire du palais
n'hésite pas à empiéter sur les
privilèges du clergé au 9e siècle
l'historien flooder écrit ce chat martel
né du concubinage d'une esclave comme on
l'est dans les annales des rois francs
plus audacieux que tous les rois ses
prédécesseurs donna non seulement les
lécher de race
mais encore beaucoup d'autres du royaume
de france à des laïcs et à des comptes
en sorte qu'il ôte à tout pouvoir aux
évêques sur les biens les affaires de
l'église
il ne s'agit ni de pillages ni d'une
razzia sur les objets du culte mais d'un
abus de pouvoir on accuse charles de
nommer des laïcs à la tête de la
puissance foncière du clergé et d'en
tirer de précieux dividendes au profit
de la noblesse
or ces accusations ne sont pas infondées
charles martel a pour compagnons
d'aventuré un moine du nom 2011
ce curieux personnage rempli à ses côtés
la fonction de conseiller et de
diplomates
en plus de participer activement aux
batailles en récompense de ses loyaux
services le chef des francs le propulse
évêque de reims sauf que cette charge
exige que me l'on soit prêt ce qu'il
n'est pas d'où la plainte justifiée de
fle dollars
quand charles eut remporté la victoire
et défait ses ennemis il chassa de son
siège le plus rigobert son parrain qu'il
avait tenus sur les seins fond de
baptême et donne à l'évêché de reims à
un nommé milo simple ton sûr et qu'il
l'avait suivi à la guerre
lemoine milon homme de confiance de
charles martel est il une exception
loin d'être un cas à part c'est la
hiérarchie même de l'église qui s'adonne
parfois aux plaisirs séculier des armes
ainsi durant la guerre civile de 714 720
l'évêque savaric d'auxerre pris la tête
d'une milice et sans parti conquérir des
villes il s'empara d'orléans de 3
d'avalon on ignore ses motivations et
ses alliances peut être chercher t-il à
devenir maire du palais de burgondie
toujours est il que l'évêque d'auxerre
se préparaient à envahir la région
lyonnaise
quand il perdit la vie alors cet évêque
négligeant sa dignité épiscopale
rassembla de partout ne troupe nombreuse
et le marché vers le haut qu'il voulait
soumettre par le faire quand soudain
frappé par la foudre divine il périt
d'une mort subite
comme on peut le constater qu'il
s'agisse de milon de reims ou de savary
d'auxerre les hommes de dieu ne se
cantonne pas toujours au lieu de prière
et il n'est pas rare de voir les paies
pendre à la soutane la nation à
conserver le souvenir de milon dans la
poésie des chansons de geste à travers
le truculent turpin de la chanson de
roland mi-longs et turpin sont tous deux
évêques de reims tous deux luttes l'épée
à la main dans les mêlées et tous deux
servent à la cour d'un chef des francs
du nom de chat à ceci près que me l'on
est au service de charles martel
turpin sera au service de charlemagne le
viiie siècle entremêle est parfois les
fonctions du clair et du guerrier
on peut en souligner la licence mais on
ne saurait reprocher à charles martel
d'avoir mordu les privilèges d'un clergé
qui n'était pas irréprochable
[Musique]
pour se convaincre des sentiments réels
de l'église envers le vainqueur de
poitiers
il suffit de se tourner vers la papauté
de l'époque
grégoire iii et l'évêque de rome 2 731 à
en 739 le pape des pêches auprès du chef
des francs deux ambassades chargés
d'objets de valeur c'est là une
initiative tellement insolite qu'elle
stupéfie les contemporains
or à cette époque par deux fois depuis
rome siège du syntt apôtre pierre le
bienheureux pape grégoire adressa au
prince charles martel une ambassade
portant les clés du vénérable tombeau de
saint pierre avec sa chaîne étaient
présents magnifique des innombrables on
n'avait jamais entendu ni vu cela par le
passé loin de le blâmer pour quelques
abus que ce soit grégoire iii adresse au
contraire c'est plus insistantes
louanges au vainqueur de poitiers
de charles martel le saint-père
sollicite protection contre les impies
sarrazin et contre le peuple des
lombards qui tient le nord de l'italie
il cherche aussi à s'extraire de la
tutelle byzantine ce pacte conclu le
pape se détacherait de l'empereur
byzantin et sur la vie des romains se
lirait audi prince charles
[Musique]
le chef des francs et donc non seulement
le sauveur de l'occident chrétien mais
de son temps même le pape en personne
l'honore en lui décernant le titre de
protecteur de l'église bientôt vient
l'heure du rappel à dieu ayant contracté
une maladie
charles martel rang le dernier souffle
le 22 octobre 741 il ya 53 ans
quel destin fils illégitime du maire du
palais pépin legros charles fut jeté en
prison à la mort de son père
à 26 ans il entame une longue marche
vers le pouvoir
il remporte entre 716 et 719 trois
batailles majeures contre ses rivaux
politiques et assoit ainsi son autorité
sur la gauche
[Musique]
à partir des années 720 il protège de
son épée les missionnaires chrétiens
partis ont saigné les saintes écritures
en germanie
[Musique]
en 732 à poitiers il écrase les
sarrasins musulmans puis en 737
il les chasse de la côte méditerranéenne
au crépuscule de sa vie il reçoit du
pape les plus précieuses loges et
pourtant charles martel ne fut jamais
roi toujours il se retint de commettre
une imprudence et se contenta de
commander au comme l'écrira au xvième
siècle le poète ronsard sera martel
gouverneur dé françois non roi de nom
mais le maître des rois
pépin le bref fils de charles martel
sera élevé sur le pavois en 751 opérant
le changement dynastique la couronne de
france passe alors des mérovingiens au
carolingien dont le nom provient de
charme
l'ascension de la ligne et carolingienne
est fulgurante à saint denis le 28
juillet 754 fait pas le dreff reçoit sur
le front des mains du pape
étienne de la sainte huile qui fait de
lui un roi de droit divin
le 25 décembre 800 à noël charlemagne
fils de pépin le bref et sacré empereur
d'occident
[Musique]
même si charles martel ne fut jamais roi
il fut le père du premier roi de france
sacré par un pas et le grand-père du
premier empereur de rome un tel destin
est inégalée dans l'histoire de notre
ultime
[Musique]